viele menschen können einfach nicht mehr
haben keine kraft mehr egal welche
maßnahmen beschlossen werden sie tragen
sie nicht mehr mit und dann gibt es noch
die die niemand mehr erreichen kann die
ihrer eigenen wirren theorien haben die
auch zu gewalt bereit sind ja auf den
straßen eine mischung aus all den
gestern abend fast hunderttausend
demonstranten in ganz deutschland in
mehr als 50 städten mittlerweile ja in
magdeburg in nürnberg in leipzig in den
soll das ganz genauso in braunschweig in
rostock in neubrandenburg weimar erfurt
altenburg saalfeld gera und und und
lichter spaziergang oder kundgebung oder
schweigemarsch heißt so etwas dann und
in sachsen sachsen anhalt und hessen kam
es zu ausschreitungen
und wir stehen jetzt gerade drei tage
vor dem nächsten corona gipfel der eine
ganz große frage hat geht bald ganz
deutschland in quarantäne jedenfalls
droht das millionen deutschen und zwar
gleichzeitig denn wenn sie kontakt
hatten zu einem omikron infizierten dann
heißt es derzeit noch ab in die
quarantäne
nikon breitet sich immer schneller aus
hoch ansteckend aber eben auch deutlich
milder als andere corona varianten
dennoch droht beim jetzigen regel stand
quarantäne für 14 tage um den quarantäne
super gau für die kritische
infrastruktur in deutschland zu
verhindern also für polizei feuerwehr
verwaltung und wirtschaft wird nun die
halbierung der omicron quarantäne
gefordert also nur sieben tage statt 14
tage aber das soll nur für doppelt
geimpfte und gemusterte gelten ein
weiterer bonus für doppelt geimpfte und
gemusterte sie sollen sich künftig
bereits nach fünf tagen frei testen
können in frankreich gilt seit montag
bereits die neue siebentägige quarantäne
regel für vollständig geimpft in den usa
kommt die verkürzung zumindest für das
gesundheitspersonal und in
großbritannien gilt für alle corona
infizierten nur noch sieben tage
isolation allerdings muss der
schnelltest an tag 6 und 7 negativ seien
strenge quarantäne regeln immer noch
andere länder haben das längst geändert
das kann auch bei uns nicht so bleiben
dass sagen jetzt immer mehr politiker
und experten sonst liegt bald das ganze
land lahm
obwohl die allermeisten gar nicht krank
sind die quarantäne könnte also verkürzt
werden und das will zum beispiel ralph
spiegler präsident des deutschen städte
und gemeindebundes
infrastruktur muss funktionieren und
wenn ein weg ist dass man medizinisch
vertretbar quarantänezeit und verkürzt
dann sollte man genau das tun also neue
quarantäne regeln und zwar quarantäne
verkürzen oder gleich ganz weg damit mit
der quarantäne fragen wir die experten
nämlich unser bild expertenrat mitte im
job biologen professor klaus stöhr mit
dem kassenärzte chef andreas gassen und
stefan kooths dem chef des kieler
instituts für weltwirtschaft in allen
schönen guten tag
guten tag an mir selber ihnen an herr
professor stöhr muss die quarantäne bei
kontakt mit einer omikron person
komplett wegfallen
quarantäne wie andere maßnahmen zur
reduktion der virus verbreitung müssen
sich an die situation anpassen je
nachdem wie lange das virus
ausgeschieden wird wie hoch
infektiös und so muss man auch die
maßnahmen über den verlauf der pandemie
anpassen und die zahlen und fakten
eigentlich klar zwar nicht aus
deutschland aber auch aus den
umliegenden ländern immer mehr menschen
infiziert immer milder gesagt sehr gute
daten jetzt aus den usa wie wenig kinder
betroffen sind fast nur weniger als
erwachsene aber wir sehen ja auch aber
wir sehen ja komplett weg oder verkürzen
wofür würden sie aktuell plädieren herr
stöhr ich würde mich gerne wiederholen
wir brauchen einen stufenplan einen der
sich anpasst eskalierend an die
entsprechende situation
es ist ja nicht so dass man linken
straßengraben gleich den rechten starken
ravensberg immunität schaltet die auch
nicht an man muss hier
adaptieren und das heißt für mich
erstmal natürlich für die geimpften
keine quarantäne mehr wenn sie kontakt
haben die franzosen sehr gut vorgemacht
die haben noch ein extra stufe
eingeschaltet die müssen sich da noch
hinterher testen und das muss man auf
allen ebenen so um den natürlichen
mittel gleich stärker noch in den
krankenhäusern weil es um den schutz der
wohl noch arbeiten geht aber auf den
entfernteren bereichen in den kader in
den schulen irgendwie jetzt wieder dass
die grünen politiker fordern dass drei
mal pro woche getestet wird ohne eine
zustimmung gegeben oder die indikatoren
seien also ja die fahrer nehmen und die
kontakt beschränkung müsst angepasst
werden das konzept weggekommen bin den
gesundheitsämtern die können ja nicht
nur nicht mehr alle kontakte
nachverfolgen das ist ja auch schon seit
langem klar aber man müsste jetzt die
ressourcen besser umlegen gleich um die
altenpflegeheime noch besser
unterstützen die schulen zu unterstützen
die systeme besser anzupassen die kinder
noch mehr zu entlasten und darauf sich
einzustellen dass das video ist eben
weitläufig zirkuliert also ja unbedingt
die kontakt kontakt reduktion an
passende konzept wechsel kein thema auch
reduzieren entsprechend dem
hydrologischen situation also einen
stufenplan herr dr gassen käme das auch
für sie in frage oder würden sie
vielleicht sogar noch einen schritt
weiter gehen dass man die quarantäne
regelungen im zweifel auch das steht
jetzt zur diskussion der teilweise ganz
abschafft
also ich bin da bei professor steuer ich
glaube die quarantäne grund jetzt
abzuschaffen wäre glaube ich nicht
sachgerecht also bei infektion
nachgewiesen infektion einer person
macht es sich ja sehen dass die einen
zeitraum zu hause bleibt er muss
sicherlich jetzt neu überdacht werden
mit nikon und er muss sicherlich auch
anders sein für doppelt geben und
gemusterte als für menschen die nicht
geimpft sind was sich ja darum
krankheitsgeschehen abzeichnet aber dass
zum beispiel eine quarantäne für
geimpfte kontaktperson eines infizierten
automat schwenker ist sicherlich nicht
wirklich adäquat und zum anderen kommen
wir zu einer völlig unüberschaubaren
menge nachher von personen weil eben
umgeht man offen sich deutlich
ansteckender glücklicherweise auch
deutlich weniger krank machen ist also
ihr muss man sicherlich anpassen und das
kann daran bestehen dass man die
quarantänezeit verkürzt analog wie in
anderen ländern ob man das
berufsgruppenspezifischen macht das
finde ich ein bisschen schwierig also
entweder gibt es medizinischen grund das
zu verkürzen dann gilt ja eigentlich für
alle und es muss natürlich selbst und
fremdgefährdung auszuschließen seien
wundern sie sich erst ein bisschen über
die regelung aktuell beim fc bayern da
gibt es einen fall nach dem nächsten und
trotzdem ist das restliche team moment
noch auf dem trainingsplatz und am
freitag wahrscheinlich auch im spiel
gegen gladbach oder ist das fc bayern
modell modell zum beispiel für alle
arbeitgeber und für alle schulklassen
das eben nur noch der manuel neuer als
seine quarantäne muss wenn der korona
positiv ist aber der rest der bayern
schulklasse wie das spielen oder
arbeiten darf also muss das wäre das
sicherlich sinnvoll man kann sich ja hat
in der vergangenheit schon dass eine
andere mal gewundert das ist zwar
fußball profis gibt die ungekürzt
spielen durften auf der anderen seite
aber in weiten teilen der bundesrepublik
kinder und jugendliche nicht ungeimpft
am sportheim also das sind natürlich
absurde regelung aber die grundsätzliche
frage wer muss in quarantäne glaube ich
kann man schon so an dass das für
infizierte natürlich gilt wie lange dann
auch immer aber für kontaktpersonen mit
negativen sex ist es ziemlich sinnfrei
winkel oder das quarantäne muss auf den
malediven das könnte man sich vom fc
bayern vielleicht auch ab schauen was
für wirtschaftliche folgen könnte das
ganze haben wie sieht's aus wir reden
immer davon dass die kritische
infrastruktur
dafür die schützen müssen aber dennoch
geht es ja um die gesamte wirtschaft
wenn jetzt zahlreiche menschen in
quarantäne müssen manchmal geht man
sogar von millionen aus herr kurz was
würde das für die wirtschaft bedeuten ja
wir hätten wir ganz klar wieder einen
stärkeren einbruch zum jahresauftakt als
wir ihn ja ohnehin jetzt erwarten wir
gehen davon aus dass wir über das
gesamte winterhalbjahr eine rückläufige
wirtschaftliche entwicklung haben werden
nicht dramatisch aber doch war
rückläufig und darin es aber eben nicht
berücksichtigt dass wir jetzt so eine
massen
charakter gleich und dann hätten wir
wieder einen stärkeren einbruch im
auftaktquartal generell sollten wir bei
dieser gesamten debatte nicht vergessen
was denn eigentlich unser ziel ist unser
ziel ist ja die kapazitäten des
gesundheitswesens nicht zu überlasten
und solange wir dort nicht in die
bedrohliche kommen sollte man dann mit
allzu drastischen maßnahmen auch eher
vorsichtig sein wir haben ja das
teilweise sogar schon in einigen
landkreisen wieder bei ihnen
schleswig-holstein herr codes in
dithmarschen hören wir heute zum
beispiel plötzlich sprunghaft
angestiegene inzidenz weiter am 18
dezember ist eine große disco
veranstaltung gab in meldorf jetzt
stellt die inzidenz da hoch und
plötzlich sind ganz viele menschen dort
in dithmarschen auf einen schlag in
quarantäne zack der landkreis in teilen
plötzlich lahm gelegt was kostet das
dann so ein landkreis oder ein
bundesland oder anschließend auch
deutschland was kostet das an jobs
also an jobs wird das erst mal
vermutlich nichts kosten zunächste
fallend eben die entsprechende
wertschöpfung aus das ist natürlich für
die betroffenen bitter aber so seltsam
ist klingt am arbeitsmarkt werden diese
maßnahmen vergleichsweise da muss ich
allerdings unterstreichen
vergleichsweise glimpflich vorbeigehen
weil es eben absehbar temporär ist das
heißt die unternehmen haben eben die
aussicht dass sie nachdem diese pandemie
vorbei ist wieder in ihre bisherigen
geschäftsmodelle zurückkehren können und
dort auch wieder geschäfte machen können
das steht nach wie vor es ist nicht so
dass die pandemie die
wirtschaft völlig umstellt sondern im
gegenteil alles drängt ja wieder zur
normalität die menschen wollen wieder
genau die
dienstleistungen
konsumieren die sie auch schon vor der
pandemie gewohnt waren das wissen auch
die unternehmen und werden deshalb alles
dafür tun die also am markt zu bleiben
jetzt sei wäre die aufgabe der politik
auch hier mit den entsprechenden
unternehmenshilfen dafür zu sorgen dass
die diese zeit auch überstehen können
das ist das entscheidende
die kurzfristigen ausfällen
wirtschaftsleistung die muss man
hinnehmen wenn andernfalls der
gesundheitsschutz zu sehr
benachteiligt würde jetzt sagt ja nicht
nur heute hier unser expertenrat jetzt
gerade bei bild live sondern auch der
der bundesregierung und geht dann seine
empfehlungen für freitag ab für die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz herr
professor stört wenn sie einsatz hätten
den sie mit geben könnten der auf diesem
papier stehen sollte der direkt an die
bundesregierung als empfehlung
weitergegeben wird welcher satz wäre das
ziel definieren indikatoren und
parameter festlegen
alternativen evaluieren entscheiden und
danach messen wie erfolgreich man ist
also in deutschland glaube ich hat man
immer das pferd oder häufig das pferd
von hinten aufgezäumt genau zum beispiel
jetzt bei der impfpflicht die man
diskutiert man nicht die fragen gestellt
welches epidemiologische und
wirtschaftliche gesundheitliche soziale
ziele sollen wir dann erreichen man hat
gesagt sie wolle jetzt eine allgemeine
impfpflicht machen er ist das gut und
ich was sind dann die alternativen hat
man die wahl wird also ich glaube der
expertenrat müssen endlich auch in einem
prozess der
entscheidungsvorbereitung und der
politischen entscheidungsfindung die sie
unterstützen von diesem normalen
die taktisch klugen prozess der
entscheidungsfindung ausgehen und da
würde ich mir wünschen solche
alternativen entwickelt werden dass man
auch die nacht den vorteilen und
nachteilen schau die kollateralschäden
evaluiert und nicht jetzt immer wieder
nach einem derselben sache ruft ein
bisschen ist der ruf jetzt wenn ich das
sagen da nach quarantäne
wendungen hintergrund gene oder weg ja
auch ein bisschen dieser diskussion
geschuldet eigentlich wäre die richtige
frage wie ist die epidemiologische
situation
und wie ist die krankheit in den
krankenhäusern auf der intensivstation
wie gesundheit werden und welche
anpassungen vorgenommen werden oder man
sucht dich erst die stellschraube an der
mann dreht wenn man weiß welche szenen
die allgemeine situation
die stellschraube waren jene ändern und
kontakt beschränkungen reduzieren ja wie
machen würde ja also das ist meines
erachtens falsche haare die falsche
herangehensweise
jedoch großen firma würde man sagen ja
macht eure hausaufgaben erst bevor ihr
mit eurem empfehlung die ursache dafür
könnte sein dass das evaluieren das
messen so schwierig ist weil man nicht
die richtigen zahlen hat lassen was ist
ihre erwartung jetzt an die
bundesregierung wie sie dieses zahlen
desaster aufräumt also so dass wir
vielleicht hoffentlich ja ende januar
wieder richtige realistische zahlen
anbieten können ich weiß selber gar
nicht wann wir wirklich realistische
zahlen hatten also ich habe meine großen
zweifel dass wir ein wirklich reales
bild infektions lage über die letzten
zwei jahre durchgängig hatten das ist
auch nichts was man jetzt in ein paar
tagen ändern kann das hängt an
veralteten strukturen das hängt auch ein
und effizienten
bindeglieder in diesen strukturen das
muss man nach der pandemie oder auch
jetzt beginnen zu ändern damit wir in
zukunft besser aufgestellt sind wichtig
ist glaube ich noch die zahlen sind ja
nur dass eine wir müssen uns glaube ich
tatsächlich wieder auf die
ursprünglichen ziele fokussieren das
geht ja und wird und kann vielleicht
noch gar nicht darum gehen möglichst
jede infektion zu erwähnen das war ja
mal einige experten haben das ja mal als
ziel ausgerufen es geht ja und zwei
dinge wir wollen versuchen schwere
erkrankungen tod zu verhindern und das
überlassen des gesundheitssystems nach
möglichkeit zu verhindern wenn diese
beiden ziele erreicht sind glaube ich
kann man insgesamt etwas gelassener
werden insbesondere bei einer virus
variante die hoch ansteckend aber offen
sich nicht so gefährlich ist und ich
denke danach müssen sich auch die mass
nacharbeiten die zahlen und daten lage
das ist etwas was wir grundsätzlich
verbessern müssen wir haben zum beispiel
bis heute ja noch schwierigkeiten die
impf meldedaten die die kassen jetzt die
vereinigung erheben über eine
schnittstelle anzag ag zu übermitteln
weil es diese schnittstelle nicht gibt
also hier sind ganz viele hausaufgaben
zu machen das muss auch fortgesetzt
werden wenn die pandemie dann in so emmi
wird aber daher würde ich mich auch
nicht völlig sklavisch an den zahlen
festmachen was die neuinfektionen jetzt
für mich sind viel entscheidender wie
viele menschen liegen auf
intensivstationen wieviel lägen in den
krankenhäusern weil
da spielt ich sage es mal salopp
formuliert medizinisch die musik
letzte frage an sie herr kurz sie haben
gerade gesagt sind die wirtschaft ich
kann das noch ein bisschen aushalten mit
der aussicht darauf dass diese zum teil
lokalen glock bei uns ja dann auch immer
wieder gelockert werden wie lange kann
die wirtschaft das aushalten wie viele
auch kleine lokale lockdown soder große
garantieren kann unsere wirtschaft mit
blick auf dieses jahr noch aushalten ja
das kann man jetzt nicht in wochen oder
monaten festmachen
es kommt ja auch dann darauf an wie weit
wir das vom staat entsprechend abfangen
auch hier sind natürlich die mittel
nicht unbegrenzt wir sollten uns auch
nicht der illusionen hergeben wir
könnten jetzt jahr für jahr aus einem
füllhorn leben was dann immer wieder
durch schulden aufgefüllt wird also auch
hier muss man natürlich
sorgsam mit den mitteln umgehen aber das
ist jetzt wie gesagt auch nicht die
entscheidende frage wir stehen nicht vor
einem kollaps der des wirtschaftssystems
wenn wir jetzt noch einmal solche
maßnahmen abgreifen müssten aber ich
kann meinen vorrednern nur
vollumfänglich zu stimmen die frage ist
geklärt werden muss brauchen wir diese
maßnahmen überhaupt und da wäre es
sicherlich auch immer ratsam zum
beispiel anderer länder zu lernen und
vor allen dingen eben hier die datenlage
in deutschland zu verbessern doch das
vielleicht noch mal sagen die haben
bereits im april
2020 also gleich zu beginn der pandemie
empfohlen dass wir eine rap eine eine
repräsentative stichprobe ziehen und die
daneben auch kontinuierlich beobachten
über die bevölkerung um das panini
geschehen tatsächlich zu erfassen und
nicht von den vielen zufälligkeiten
immer wieder
getrieben zu werden
und deshalb wäre es eben wirklich
wichtig an den daten zu arbeiten das ist
jetzt nichts was kurzfristig war mutig
gelingen kann aber irgendwann muss man
ja mal anfangen
wir sind jetzt schon im oder wir gehen
jetzt bald in das dritte jahr der
pandemie und ich kann nicht erkennen
dass ich an der an der front also bei
der repräsentativen datenerhebung
wirklich etwas substanzielles verbessert
ja das können wir auch nicht erkennen er
professor kurt so kann man kein
wirtschaftsunternehmen führen oder
nein so würde man das nicht führen das
ist jetzt auch keine raketenwissenschaft
sondern das liegt eigentlich auf der
hand und ist es wirklich bedauerlich
dass wir das nicht geschafft haben und
das kann man eben jetzt nicht nur mit
mangelnder digitalisierung und
dergleichen erklären da macht man sich
einen viel zu schlanken fuß hier geht es
eben auch darum was wollte man
eigentlich
oder
[Musik]
was hat man sich zugetraut und hier
würde ich mal sagen hat man sich
vielleicht zu wenig zugetraut scharfe
kritik vom kieler institut für
weltwirtschaft danke professor stefan
kooths scharfe kritik an der
bundesregierung gleichzeitig von unserem
experten raten klarer auftrag für die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz am freitag
mit blick auf neue quarantäne regeln
vielen dank an unseren bild expertenrat
hierbei mit live
[Musik]
und jetzt schauen wir mal auf die
aktuellen zahlen wie das lka heute
morgen herausgegeben hat nikon könnte ja
der übergang zur enden werden also das
heißt das virus mutiert zu einer
erkältung und das wollen wir uns einmal
genauer anschauen was das für uns alle
bedeuten würde jetzt also die ganz
aktuellen zahlen die noch immer laut rk
ii
naja nicht wirklich das bild
widerspiegeln die die korona situation
hier in deutschland ist dennoch sie
geben eine tendenz vor deswegen also
jetzt der blick auch hier auf die karte
ja und 110 wir ganz klar in dieser chor
ohne hotspots karte ich habe den
vergangenen wochen immer wieder gesagt
dass fährt sich so langsam gelb ein
teilweise grün ein wir hatten einzelne
grüne flecken niedersachsen in schleswig
holstein und jetzt wird das wieder ein
bisschen roter vor allen dingen ganz
oben in schleswig-holstein kreis
dithmarschen richtig macht im moment ein
bisschen sorge da gibt es eine hohe
intelligenz unter den zehn landkreisen
mit der höchsten zahl an neuinfektionen
liegen nun drei landkreise im norden
also es gibt hotspots in niedersachsen
im landkreis verden in bremen und in
schleswig-holstein dithmarschen
angesprochen weiterhin angespannt das
kennen wir bereits aus den letzten
wochen ist die lage weiterhin in
thüringen brandenburg und sachsen ja die
inzidenz lag deutlich niedriger vor
sieben tagen heißt aber gar nicht dass
die lage sich verschlechtert hat in der
zeit sondern die zahlen stimmten
natürlich vor sieben tagen auch noch
weniger als sie heute stimmen also es
gibt da jetzt verschiebungen über die
weihnachtszeit er sieht man auch an
diesem fall dithmarschen da gab es diese
disco veranstaltung vor weihnachten
jetzt sind die daten da jetzt steigt die
inzidenz jetzt fährt sich die karte
wieder rot ein also das ist das was wir
ihnen zu bieten haben im moment ganz
ähnlich wie gestern aus china sind die
krankenhäuser eben gerade auch noch mal
von doktor gassen gesagt das ist
eigentlich der wert erzählt erzählt vor
allem deshalb weil sich daran ja auch
die maßnahmen hier in deutschland
orientieren deswegen heute der blick auf
die krankenhäuser die krankenhaus
instanz in deutschland die liegt heute
bei 3,2 am montag im vergleich hatte sie
noch bei 3,62 gelingen ist also leicht
gesunken nur zum vergleich den höchsten
wert den hatten wir um die
weihnachtszeit 2020 da lag er bei rund
15,7 5 und da schauen jetzt einmal auf
die deutschlandkarte wie es so aussieht
das ist ja gestaffelt
ein wert ab 3 an wert ab sechs abwehr ab
9 und daran orientieren sich dann die
maßnahmen ganz klar ist die geringer der
wert desto offener desto freier kann man
leben das sind die gebiete die hier grün
eingezeichnet sind wo der wert unter
drei liegt also beispielsweise bayern
und nordrhein westfalen und baden
württemberg unternehmen im osten
deutschland da wird es dann gelb orange
und thüringen der höchste wert mit 9,86